adam pletko gets the start tonight it
was supposed to be mike clevenger chris
brian leads off and he drives one high
in the air to left center back goes
luplow and the left fielder will make
the catch and chris bryant is out number
one here's anthony rizzo chops it on the
ground
two away
and the batter is javier baya swung on a
weak bouncer to third the chest high hop
handled by ramirez he throws over and
it's a one two three on the bottom of
the first inning no score and one of
terry francona's all-time favorite
players on the hill that being the
left-hander john lester john lester's
ready to go
and he's going to get
one pitch not a great throw by
bryant but it worked out just as it did
in 2016. and hernandez is out ramirez
hitting 273.
swinging a pop-up easy play shallow
right going out and
making the catches the former indian
jason kipnis and that's out number two
frankie lindor in the scoreless first
swung on grounded sharply in the hole
and shallow left backhanded pick jump
throw by baez off target and it hits
first base coach sandy alamar and stays
right by the coaching box and an infield
hit for frankie lindor here's carlos
santana 3-2 way outside and high ball
four
first walk yielded by john lester ron
mio reyes with two on two out swinging a
miss strike three got him on a change up
the indians get a hit and a walk but
they walk away empty-handed cubs have a
scoring chance men at first and second
with one away jason hayward
full count runners on the move and a
bullet into center that'll get down
contreras around third
and it's one one-nothing cubs here's
victor caratini let's see if the cubs
now can get a big inning check swing
tapper toward third near the bag gloved
on the backhand by ramirez steps throws
to first in the dirt great backhanded
pick by santana oh that wasn't an easy
double play to turn but ramirez and
santana did and pletco needed that jason
kipnis takes off the batting helmet and
doffs it towards his teammates in the
first base dugout they were giving him a
standing ovation jason kipnis a fixture
for nine years at second base for the
indians
rocket into the corner and right
and kipnis doubles down the right field
line in his first at-bat
as a non-indian and progressive field
and the batter will be chris bryant
swung on a little weak fly ball shallow
right center charging to shields dives
and made the catch that was a terrific
play because it was off the end of the
bat so you didn't think it was going to
stay up in the air very long cubs don't
want to waste a lead off double by
kipnis two outs jason's still at second
and here's baez swings and misses got
him with the curveball
so adam pletko gave up the leadoff
double but no damage done now there's
runners on the corners with two down
brings up domingo santana there's a big
chop slowly hit to a charging bride at
third gloves it plants the feet throws
him out the indians who threaten but do
not score
and now a big mess base is loaded for
wilson contreras contreras hits a high
fly ball into deep right center but it's
playable a run will score de shields
makes the catch tagging as bryant
sacrifice fly wilson contreras and the
cubs lead by a pair ian hat batting with
men at first and third two down line
toward the middle that's a base hit pass
to diving lindor another run is in and
the cubs now lead three to nothing
philamenton to face jason hayward deep
drive to right off the bat of hayward
back to the wall gone
three run homer jason hayward cubs break
it open what a night for hayward he's
knocked in four and it's six to nothing
lester has blanked the indians on two
harmless hits four strikeouts two walks
reyes sends a drive toward the gap in
deep right center field and this ball
one hops the wall and stays in play
that'll enable lindor to score from miel
reyes with a double and the indians
finally get
to john lester swinging a high pop fly
right center easy chance
hap is camping underneath pulling it
down and that ends the inning lester
gives up one run in six solid innings if
indeed this is the end of his night it
was a good one hypnos goes to third of
two down and let's see if baez can drive
in the run that gets away
and kipnis scores
7-1
colin ray stays on the pitch for chicago
two gone the indians down to their last
chance swinging a fly ball right field
playable for hayward and the cubs win
the ball game
the chicago cubs beat the cleveland
indians by a score of seven to one